blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
last night joe biden delivered his first
speech to a joint
session of congress the senate coming
over to the house of representatives to
hear joe biden deliver this speech
not called the state of the union it's
typically not called the state of the
union when it's a president's first year
in office but it is essentially a state
of the union and joe biden
did lay out his plan for a 1.8 trillion
dollar
spending package including funding paid
leave community college
and all of the things we previewed in
some detail yesterday so i won't redo
the policy proposal nitty gritty again
but it was overall
a very policy heavy speech this could
not have been more different from recent
state of the union addresses from donald
trump which contained
almost no policy but trump aside
even compared to barack obama compared
to george w bush before him
it was really just a focus on policy
with very little vapid political
rhetoric now that's not necessarily good
or bad
vapid political rhetoric can be a good
thing if it's inspirational or
coalesces people or it can be nonsense
or whatever but
this was really a focus on policy a
focus on vaccination
even ted cruz here applauding after joe
biden
announces 220 million vaccine doses in a
hundred days
and urges everybody to get themselves
vaccinated
right now right away go get
vaccinated america go and get the
vaccination
they're available
you're eligible now
joe biden talking about those
vaccination numbers but also talking
a lot about job creation
all this is all going on the economy
created
more than 1 million 300
000 new jobs in 100 days more jobs with
first
more jobs in the first hundred days than
any
president on record the international
monetary fund
international now of course that is
true context does matter
we were and are in a recovery period
from an externally motivated job loss
caused by the pandemic now many of those
jobs are coming back
you expect any president to brag about
job growth
whether or not they had a hand in it it
is still a good thing but it is
important to understand the context
many of these jobs would be coming back
regardless of who was president i'd
rather it be joe biden than donald trump
for sure
joe biden then jumping right into
talking about the economy and talking
about
the importance of unions much to bernie
sanders delight
and unions built the middle class
so that's why i'm calling on congress
to pass protect the right to organize
act the pro act and send it to my desk
so we can support
the right to unionize
and by the way and joe biden then
much to the pleasure of most democrats
in the crowd but not mitt romney
and lauren beaubert and others saying
let's raise the minimum wage to fifteen
dollars an hour
let's raise the minimum wage to fifteen
dollars
no one
no one working 40 hours a week
no one working 40 hours a week should
live below the poverty line
we need to ensure greater equity and
opportunity for women and while we're
doing this let's get the paycheck
fairness act to my desk
as well equal pay they spent much too
long
and if you wonder whether it's too long
look behind me
joe biden also laying out how he will
pay for
much of these ideas saying the rich will
pay and mitt romney didn't seem
particularly thrilled with that either
and the wealthiest one percent of
americans have just begun to pay their
fair share
just their fair share
[Music]
sometimes i have arguments with my
friends in the democratic party
i think you should be able to become a
billionaire and a millionaire but
pay your fair share and on economics
a moment that many people liked which
got
a lot of attention joe biden saying
straight up
trickle-down economics has never worked
my fellow americans trickle down
trickle down economics has never worked
and it's time to grow the economy from
the bottom in the middle out
you know now i love this because
i already planned later today to talk
about
joe biden and bidenomics as they are
being called
as the antithesis to reaganomics
that line uh trickle-down economics has
never worked
is actually part of it saying it as
directly as anybody can and we're going
to come back to that in more detail
on foreign policy joe biden pointing out
that
he's just getting out of afghanistan
something that republicans loved when it
was trump who announced it
trump failed to do it joe biden is doing
it
and republicans are no longer clapping
about it and american leadership means
ending the forever war in afghanistan
we have
we have without hyperbole the greatest
fighting force in history of the world
i'm the first president 40 years and
knows what it means to have a son
serving in a war zone today we have
service members serving in the same war
zone as their parents did
we have service members in afghanistan
who are not yet born
on 9 11. the war in afghanistan as we
remember the debates here
were never meant to be
multi-generational undertakings
of nation-building of course it was
never really about
just getting out of afghanistan it was
can we cheer for something trump is
doing
biden now is actually going to do the
thing we cheered trump for announcing
but we don't cheer anymore
because we are merely political
hypocrites real quick here is senator
ted cruz
sleeping during the speech he looked
very very sleepy apparently dreaming of
cancun
and joe biden ultimately closing out
his speech take a listen to that it's
never
ever ever been a good bet to bet against
america
and it still isn't we're the united
states of america
there's not a single thing nothing
nothing beyond our capacity
we can do whatever we set our mind to if
we do it together
so let's begin to get together
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
thank you for your patience
some of the people in the camp of biden
is a weakling and he's old and senile
and demented we're expecting a very
short speech
and a very incoherent speech biden going
much longer than recent presidents have
during their uh first joint addresses to
congress
and very coherent i thought it was a
well-written speech
i thought it was about the right
duration i often think things are too
long i think it was about the right
duration
and now actually comes the tough part
which is joe biden has laid out a
variety of different policy ideas
can joe biden get any of what he
proposed
done and that is certainly easier said
than done when not only do you have
zero republican support in the house and
senate
for anything you want to do but it's not
even clear you have the support of all
of the democrats in the senate either
and we will talk about that as these
proposals become more formalized and
start to be debated
the reaction from republicans to joe
biden's first speech before a joint
session of congress
was pathetic childish and ignorant which
are three adjectives that
they often i could be describing almost
anything the republican party has done
over the last few years
as pathetic childish and ignorant and it
would be accurate
republican senator tim scott gave the
formal rebuttal and we'll get to a
couple of clips of that
but fox news gave the informal rebuttal
as i'm calling it and we're going to
look at clips
of that as well immediately after the
speech
in an interview with fox's sean hannity
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
again brought up that joe biden wants to
control
how much red meat each american eats
this was never believable from the start
it's now been totally debunked and a
different fox news program
actually apologized for falsely
reporting that joe biden wanted to
control meat eating
mccarthy doesn't care he repeats it
again he just continues
he wants control of your life he's going
to control how much meat you can eat
can you imagine that then here is a fox
news host
sean hannity complaining about how joe
biden walked he didn't like
the the gates that's g-a-i-t of joe
biden walking into the speech
you watch the the i call it the biden
shuffle
it's like uh you know the little baby
steps that he takes as he walks and
little elbows looks like it's an effort
i
there doesn't seem to be a vitality
in in in how he approaches this
very substantive as you can tell and
by the way it's weird to complain about
how joe biden walks
when donald trump had to be helped down
the ramp at west point by a military
general but
what do i know it seems that people in
glass glass houses
shouldn't throw stones but uh apparently
sean hannity having nothing left but
that to do
senator ted cruz who again you know
earlier we saw dozing off
during joe biden's speech he summed the
speech
up this way well look i think the speech
tonight
you could sum up in three words boring
but radical and then much of the
reaction
was not about the proposals but about
masks and distancing check this out
by the way this needs to be said you
know all the people in that room
they've been fully vaccinated congress
they they were first in line
back in december uh we do we not have an
explanation why can't that room be full
why is everyone still wearing masks now
of course
we know the answers to these questions
they always
they love you know when when your
audience is uninformed and doesn't know
any better
you can ask questions and pretend we
don't have answers
and get them on board by saying yeah
then why don't we have the answer to
that but we have the answers
the cdc guidelines are vaccinated people
do not have to wear masks in small
indoor gatherings
there is still enough of an unvaccinated
population
and 50 000 cases a day spreading that
at a large event people should wear
masks
regardless of vaccination status in part
because you don't know everybody's
vaccination status
the house chamber with 200 people in it
even if it's not the full 535 members of
congress plus staff that would normally
be there
it's not a small group vaccination was
not mandatory rand paul i think didn't
get his
i don't remember now but i think you
know you do not know the vaccination
status of everyone in the room it's not
a small group
that's why it's not super complicated
that's why they're wearing masks
plus so many of hannity's followers
are so dumb that if they saw a room full
of 535 people without masks
they would think it's okay for them and
their unvaccinated friends to start
doing whatever the hell they want so
the answer is actually quite simple as
to why this is the way it was done
the defenders of uh donald trump also
are suddenly very concerned about the
nuances of cdc guidelines here is
another from fox news they were never
concerned about trump's rallies or
anything
listen to the concern now well first i
want to talk about what i what i'm
seeing
and you know martha you mentioned these
people who are all vaccinated being
indoors socially distancing with their
masks on
that's against cdc guidance it's not
just that that's theater it actually
shows that the united states is at a
weak point when the congress can't show
up
in full uh to show that the united
states is standing strong
after coming out of a pandemic that was
caused
by china i mean if you give a joint
address to a congress that is not even
half full
does it really even count as a joint
address to congress i mean i think
that's
really a question the other thing that i
yes we look
weak because there weren't more people
at joe biden's speech give me a break
guys
here's one more about this basically the
only thing that fox news had to talk
about
was masking and distancing i think it's
worth
noting at the top just the feel of this
room
and the fact that he talked a lot in the
beginning about covid about pulling
through
kovid and getting through this era
that really marked so much of his
candidacy
and yet you have this new cdc guidance
that came out
just this week which said and i'll read
it to you
fully vaccinated people can visit other
fully vaccinated people
indoors without wearing masks or social
distancing
so you just have to ask yourself if this
is setting an example
looking forward for the country of what
everyone can expect
the country to be like in this period
where people now
have very open availability to vaccines
really asking the tough questions huh in
his formal response to joe biden
republican senator tim scott referred to
what
he says was the most inclusive economy
of his lifetime
under donald trump before covid
thanks to our bipartisan work last year
job openings are rebounding
so why do we feel so divided
anxious a nation with so much cause for
hope
should not feel so heavy laden
a president who promised to bring us
together
should not be pushing agendas that
tear us apart the american family
deserves better
and we know what better looks like just
before covid
we have the most inclusive economy in my
lifetime
you know i really don't recall that
magical period
of bipartisanship and unity under trump
that tim scott
is referring to trump in fact
statistically
has been the most divisive president in
the modern polling era
but he wants us to believe it was ginger
snaps and candy waterfalls and rainbows
and all of this stuff
and overall i mean tim scott's response
was just very weak
it felt like it had no testicular
fortitude
behind it here's one more clip our
public schools should have reopened
months ago other countries did
private and religious schools did
science has shown for
months that schools are safe but too
often powerful grown-ups set science
aside
and kids like me were left behind
of course more and more schools are open
and things are opening and it's like
this
is your criticism much of it doesn't
even have to do with joe biden a lot of
these school decisions or state
decisions
individual school decisions i know
school principals i know people on
boards of education and it's not joe
biden that's deciding
anyway so a completely vapid
flaccid substance-free reaction to joe
biden's speech both
in terms of the official response by
republican senator tim scott
and by fox news and the fact that they
have
nothing substantive once again is a sign
that joe biden
is generally speaking on the right track
because the critiques aren't substantive
because joe biden is proposing things
that are widely speaking popular
necessary and well received by the
american people
let me know what you thought of the
speech you can find me on twitter at
deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect
for exploring a book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for if there's a full
book you're thinking about buying
you can use blinkist to get a sample
first just think
how much you can enrich yourself by
being able to soak up an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check
it out on blinkist blinkist has books on
politics philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
mostly funded by members who
sign up at joinpackman.com
grab a membership this is a really
interesting piece
in the new york in the los angeles times
rather by doyle mcmanus called
joe biden has become the anti-reagan
and his speech to congress will make
that clear now this was of course
written before
last night's speech but it was really
confirmed by the address joe biden gave
to a joint session of congress last
night
joe biden and his bidenomics his
economic ideas as they're being called
are truly based on the opposite
principles of reaganomics reaganomics
boiled down was
supply side economics sometimes called
trickle down
the belief that cutting government
spending is good for the economy cutting
taxes
income taxes and capital gains taxes
particularly on the rich is good for the
economy
reducing regulation on business is good
for the economy tightening the money
supply is good for the economy
and also reaganomics includes the idea
that giving
people help will make them lazy joe
biden
and biodynamics as they've been dubbed
are the
exact opposite of reaganomics now to be
really clear
this doesn't have to mean that biden is
ultra left or is left as bernie or
whatever
but his views are truly the opposite of
reaganomics reaganomics is supply side
economics
joe biden is demand side stimulate the
economy with spending and by increasing
demand reaganomics is about cutting
government spending they almost think
you can cut your way to prosperity
joe biden believes you increase
government spending on the right things
and that's good for the economy it
creates jobs it injects money
into small business reaganomics is
cutting income taxes and capital gains
especially for the rich
but biodynamics is about increasing them
on the people most able to pay since we
know that the hoarding of money by those
people
is not economically stimulative compared
to well thought out properly targeted
government programs
reaganomics wants to reduce regulation
on business and let it rip let them do
whatever the hell they want
joe biden recognizes we must regulate
in order to prevent the further
destruction of our environment which
long term would be terrible for the
world and of course terrible for the
american economy
reaganomics wants to cut the money
supply often they want higher federal
funds rates
biodynamics is about increasing the
money supply
through thoughtful stimulus spending
while reaganomics would have you believe
that if you give people help it makes
them lazy
the biden idea is that if you give
people help
you make it so that they're not
constantly treading water trying to
avoid drowning
they will become more innovative they
will be more predisposed to become more
productive members of society
notice that nothing about the biden view
is remotely socialist it's almost really
just keynesianism it's a different
form of capitalism some people don't
like that
some people didn't like the fdr new deal
because they were well to the left
socialists wouldn't really have liked
the new deal because it did a lot
to sort of cement industry in american
uh the american economy
it's similar with biden there's nothing
socialist about this and as doyle
mcmanus writes in the la times piece
reagan made people hate government and
then debate
whether government should do anything at
all because the default is government is
bad
joe biden's approach is government doing
things can be popular
if they are done correctly if they are
the right things to begin with
vaccine distribution coveted stimulus
are two great starting points because
they're so popular even with many
republicans
that could then build goodwill towards
the proposals
like what joe biden outlined at last
night's speech
this is very different than what we saw
after reagan which was the demonization
of government
the constant drum beat about cut
programs cut social programs
and we could be entering a new era now i
don't say that hyperbolically it's just
you know there are errors eventually
errors change
we could be shifting to government being
seen as a tool
to help people if the tool is used
correctly
even republicans we have to admit under
trump
sort of drifted away from as much
demonization of government you still saw
it of course
but they've drifted away from it a
little bit and part of it is that while
the republican party is busy fighting
this culture war
they've completely abandoned whoa sorry
i punched my mic they've completely
abandoned
policy if the options are government
doing stuff under biden
or nothing happens either way while
republicans just talk about the culture
war in dr
seuss government doing things starts to
look
quite good and that's part of why we see
a strong support among republicans
comparatively for joe biden on
vaccination
as well as joe biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar coveted stimulus so we are going
to follow this very closely but
the antithesis of reaganomics appears to
be
what joe biden is rolling out as
economic policy
things have suddenly taken a very ugly
turn for donald trump's i guess former i
do we know former lawyer rudy giuliani
rudy giuliani's apartment and office
have been raided by federal
investigators as part of an
investigation
into possible crimes committed by rudy
giuliani this is an absolute blockbuster
situation
for a number of reasons but understand
that rudy is being investigated for
possible crimes committed
while working as the personal lawyer for
a sitting president of the united states
there is a ton we don't yet know about
what's going on but we are slowly
learning it
the new york times has a very good
report what we know is that
search warrants were executed at both
rudy's home in office
investigators seized what are being
reported as multiple laptops and mobile
phones
this took place yesterday morning at 6
00 am
that's relevant if you come in at 6 00
am at both the home and office
simultaneously
i asked on twitter actually is the
execution
of the rudy search warrant at 6am
relevant if you do it that way
is it a sign you're worried he'll try to
destroy evidence
if you come in calmly or schedule it and
indeed former fbi agent asha rangapa
responded to me that quote
most searches happen early in the
morning primarily there is simply a
greater likelihood that the subject will
be home
as you note it will also be less likely
to be observed with time to destroy
evidence etc
and in the case of dangerous individuals
it's safer for
agents now of course rudy's lawyer and
rudy himself are saying this is
outrageous
this is not necessary certainly not at
6am he's being treated like a criminal
this is a 76 year old man
rudy giuliani's lawyer robert costello
remember
maga means making attorneys get
attorneys
trump's lawyer's lawyer robert costello
put out a statement saying quote
what they did today was legal thuggery
why would anyone do
this to anyone why would you do this to
anyone let alone someone who was the
associate attorney general
united states attorney the mayor of new
york city and the personal lawyer to the
45th
president of the united states that'll
be evaluated if
feds acted inappropriately with the raid
or doing it at 6am or whatever it'll be
determined
but in the meantime a real practical
question is
do we really think evidence is still
around and what i mean is these guys
have had more than a year
to destroy it all haven't they almost
certainly done it
or at least tried it is true that the
fbi has a way of recovering things
you think you've deleted but the point
is rudy knows he's been at least a
possible target for a while
one other takeaway they are starting to
claim on the right
that this is a abide in directed
political hit job
we have no reason to believe that that's
the case but we actually have reason to
believe it's not
and the new york times reported that
investigators were looking for a search
warrant to do this
and get rudy's mobile devices and such
while trump was still president
but political appointees of donald trump
to the justice department blocked it
so this actually predates joe biden
they were investigating this during
trump and they weren't able to do the
search warrant because trump appointees
blocked it
so it is that obstruction not joe biden
which has led to this taking place in
april
rather than when donald trump was still
president of the united states
truly stunning stuff how far will this
go as a problem for rudy we don't know
but it's not looking very good
later on in the show we'll hear from
rudy's son and his reaction
to this and we'll have continued
coverage of this
on the david pakman show instagram page
make sure you are following us there
at david pakman show follow me on
instagram david.pacman
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
it's great to welcome ann newman to the
program today
author and columnist and we are going to
be talking about
vaccines operation warp speed there
there are really so many things to
discuss and so maybe maybe to start
operation warp speed i interviewed a
republican strategist recently
and she very adamantly pointed to
operation warp speed and donald trump as
the reason
why so many vaccines are now available i
asked exactly what trump did
she didn't really have anything to tell
me so let let's start there i mean
what exactly did operation warp speed
achieve that wouldn't otherwise have
been achieved what was trump's role in
that
yeah trump set this up um as instead of
you know opening up the market to the
world
and trying to make these uh formulas
accessible to everyone
he kind of made this pool of money that
incentivized six individual companies
we're talking 10 billion dollars
probably up to 18
billion at this point um and these six
companies received a huge amount of
money
as well as exclusivity um so they were
paid
say 190 uh you know 1.95
billion dollars for research yes but
then also an additional amount
for vaccines and
those vaccines that payment was
guaranteed whether the vaccines worked
or not
so what it did was pull a whole bunch of
mines in one place
and dump tons of money into them with
this concept that a free market
um which of course is not free right
that's like the perfect example of a
form of socialism yeah would it would um
accelerate the development of these
vaccines
meanwhile the mrna research was already
being worked on
by the national institutes of health so
like all pharmaceutical innovation this
was grandly subsidized not just
monetarily but also research-wise
by um by federal um entities
now i've i've read i i read things that
are
essentially it seems as though both
can't possibly be true on the one hand
i'm reading about
uh how the pharmaceutical companies are
not uh releasing the formula for
manufacturing vaccines so that other
countries could just start producing
them right away rather than waiting on
the supply flow
from the companies that are producing
them now at the same time
i read that for example in 2020
i don't remember if it was pfizer modern
or both said that they were open
sourcing the recipe if someone wants to
produce it
but it does seem as though there is
significant infrastructure and fixed
costs necessary to do that where
maybe it's not actually going to get
vaccines to people more quickly
if a new country wants to start
manufacturing what is the truth about
that
yeah it's um it's really hard to parse
because the
ip patent um special manufacturing
um categories also there's a category um
undisclosed information like since the
reagan era pharmaceutical companies have
employed um a whole raft of special
categories that are covered
um and set up to protect their profit
basically
um and so even though moderna last fall
i believe it was in october yeah
as you mentioned said sure enough our
our
patent is we won't enforce our patent
is what they said yes which uh it was a
great pr play for them
but it basically didn't do anything
because there are these other
layers of intellectual property
enforcement that can be employed
whenever anyone gets involved and you
know i talked to dean baker for the
article
that i wrote for the baffler and baker
who's an expert on intellectual
property said um you know they um
there are many ways that uh the
government
could make this information available
um so intellectual property is being
used to cover
not just the formula for the recipes but
also these
techniques and manufacturing processes
that really could just be disclosed as
easily as any recipe
i mean there's nothing that prevents
manufacturers
of pharmaceuticals from sharing that
information
as well except that they're getting
ridiculously rich
now as a practical question i'll give
you one situation that's happening in
argentina
where i was born and have a lot of
family argentina is primarily using the
sputnik vaccine which um many
love because it's open source and now
argentina has announced that they are
going to start
manufacturing it and uh some of my
uncles are very very happy who who are
loyalists to the current administration
but when i actually look into the
details
the ramp if it's even true right let's
assume it's true that argentina will
start manufacturing this if it's even
true
the ramp up process will take so long
that by the time argentina could be
making any of these sputnik vaccines
argentina won't need them and it will
really be used to take something that's
open source
and sell it to even poorer countries in
south america
to make money in argentina so i'm is
like is
is that good or is the scale-up process
really even possible to do quickly
enough that it wouldn't just make sense
to get an order in for vaccines rather
than look at making them oneself
i'm just thinking out loud here well
like anything else it's distribution
and information right that's um what
hinders
um the the sharing of any kind of
material and so distribution
um access to the apis or the um
the active pharmaceutical ingredients
ingredients
um the um technology and the materials
um could be uh better negotiated
right there's no central power that is
making sure that the countries who need
this technology
and these formulas are going to get them
and that's the real problem
i mean there are a number of
organizations that at the very beginning
said
all right this is going to be big and as
a globe we need to work together
to to make sure that everyone has the
same access
that medical ethics is employed in the
distribution of these very necessary
medicines and obviously bill gates came
in
um who's playing um this unnecessarily
large role in public health
health around the globe with an
extraordinary amount of goodwill and he
basically co-opted the system
to make it so that everything was run
through
large pharmaceutical companies um and so
here we are with this
crazy bottleneck i also want to
emphasize that in other countries around
the world there are other issues
i um i don't want to take um
india's uh modi off the table
as a stumbling block people are making
bad decisions
all around the world we also know that
on other continents
including our own there are corrupt
governments and corrupt
politicians um and so i think on the
whole
as a as a globe we were completely
unprepared for what was coming our way
and we never
had a strong voice the united states
never demonstrated any kind of
leadership
and certainly during the trump
administration we were
incredibly isolationist in how our
politics were
discussed and and um and mediated
um so i think that america first
isolationism
also put us very much behind so it's not
just the fact that these
vaccines are hard to get a hold of
because of patents and and
these layers of ip protection but it's
that also
the um the you know just the the
understanding of we need to work
together to make sure this happens just
isn't there
when it comes to the dramatic increase
in actual vaccinations that has taken
place
over the last uh few few months
was this naturally going to happen no
matter who was president or does the
biden administration
get credit for what they've what they've
done
i think that's a good question i think
certainly biden coming in removed a lot
of the animosity
um he's been clear with messaging i
think there was so much misinformation
whether that's by design in our current
media landscape or just an
administration that really didn't care
about the rest of the world dying
didn't care about the disparity in the
united states where blacks and people of
color
were unable to access vaccine doses
so i think definitely it's a change and
tone and tenor mean a lot
um but yeah pharmaceuticals are going to
pharmaceutical and
they are working non-disclosure
contracts with countries around the
world
that's a huge incentive for them not
only have they kind of recouped
their um their reputation with all of
this
they've designed the vaccine um but they
um they're also making bank
when you think oh let's talk about that
a little bit is it that profitable to do
this
and i i again i'm you read so many
things that point in different
directions with pfizer for example from
what i've seen
the entire vaccination program seems to
have affected revenue by about 1.8
percent now
it's such a big company that 1.8 percent
is a lot of dollars but in terms of
year-over-year changes it doesn't seem
dramatic so what how should we be
thinking of that as a profit center
we should be thinking long-term because
that's what the farmers are doing
wow they're they're looking at the fact
that we've got strains coming not only
do we have
you know a huge percentage of the world
that hasn't received a vaccine yet
right um they're thinking when the
crisis
is over they can raise the cost of each
dose to
you know the normal 125 150
range instead of the 18 to 34 that
they're getting each dose now
for the possible future variant boosters
for example but
but also for the possible variant
boosters not only just getting the
vaccine out to the globe but then
following up
and this might be an annual thing for us
just like the flu yeah right we're not
sure
how long we're going to remain have to
remain on this
vaccination schedule but also um
the entire vaccine industry has been
changed by covet 19.
in the past big pharma wasn't very
interested in it because it was
you know low cost a lot of generics were
being used
right um and a quick aside here is that
india manufactures 80
of the drugs that we use in the united
states so when we talk about
manufacturing elsewhere it's not like
big pharma manufactures its own drugs
anyway
right right they farm that out quite
often and secondly
um 70 of the materials for manufacturing
drugs come from
china so the drug supply chain has
already
been precarious for several decades so
um the vaccine industry never really
appealed to pharma because it wasn't a
big
money maker you know you get your
smallpox vaccine and that's it
they prefer the very expensive drugs
that have to be taken every day
say cancer drugs or rare diseases and
that's where their big money is and so
what operation
warp speed did was dump a whole bunch of
money into the vaccine industry and make
it very profitable
and bestow a crazy amount of goodwill on
these companies
last thing i want to talk about when we
think about the trajectory
for vaccinating the world and we know
that there are countries that
uh we're talking 2022 we're talking
2023. you know different estimates
one says 2024 until you really have full
vaccination in some parts of the world
ultimately will the bottleneck be
a manufacturing and distribution
bottleneck will it be an intellectual
property bottleneck what is the one
thing that if it changed could move that
date up
countries are so different our
relationships with them are so different
it's really hard to say
but i believe that it's probably going
to be the distribution
and the manufacturing and those special
manufacturing techniques
um and that's just a lack of
coordination
but that's not to say like like
intellectual property law
is kind of the umbrella term for a whole
bunch of things
right so if companies are willing to
share their
drug patents but not willing to share
special manufacturing techniques
it's the same thing they're they're
causing
um other um manufacturing entities out
there
from getting up to speed on distributing
this right it would be like if i have a
really complicated souffle
i could give you the list of ingredients
but the technique as to
what i do with the ingredients is
essentially just as important
right exactly uh we've been speaking
with anne newman
author and columnist uh and i so
appreciate your time today to talk about
this really important topic
yeah i agree thank you for covering this
thank you very much
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
davidpakmanshow so earlier in the
program we covered the fbi raid on rudy
giuliani's
house apartment and office
and we are still waiting to learn more
about what exactly is going on
what crimes is rudy suspected of and
more information about that i have to
play some of these clips for you
of rudy giuliani's son andrew giuliani
as well as just a random neighbor of
rudy's who seems to be straight out of
central casting
making statements to the media yesterday
outside rudy's uh
homer office we'll start with rudy's son
this is andrew giuliani
saying that what is going on here should
make it is
it's all political and everybody should
be furious take a look at this
mind you i'm speaking as a son and a
concerned american
anybody any american whether you're red
or blue
should be extremely disturbed by what
happened here today
by the continued politization of the
justice department
this is disgusting this is absolutely
absurd
and it's the continued politization of
the justice department that we have
seen so not exactly doing like a great
job there
and then this is just so funny andrew
giuliani says
there is important evidence in my
father's
uh home and office it's a hunter biden's
laptop
but the feds did not actually take that
the real evidence of crimes
andrew says i mean it's the apple does
not fall far from the tree
is hunter biden's laptop which they
didn't take the only piece of evidence
that they did not take up there today
was the only piece of incriminating
evidence
that is in there and it does not belong
to my father
it belongs to the current president's
son
they have figured out a way to make this
about hunter biden's laptop
somehow and i don't know that andrew
giuliani is really doing his dad any any
favors there now here's another funny
thing just for flavor and
and context one of rudy's neighbors
in the building she appears to be
straight out of central casting
she gave a statement it's not clear
whether she was just walking back from
getting groceries and stepped up to the
mic or if she was asked to come down i
mean this is just absolutely perfect
she expresses being amused when her
ex-husband called her and said hey
there's a raid going on there look out
your window the funniest thing is my
ex-husband called me
and said have you seen what's going on
and i i said he said no look out your
window
so here is more from rudy's neighbor
michelle herbert i love this woman i
know i just saw people i probably saw
fbi jackets
but i just saw people you know and i saw
all of you and
and i said what is going on
every detail is just written for
a movie and then on fox news's the five
jesse waters i guess in a serious
manner suggests they really should have
raided
uh hunter biden's house not rudy
giuliani's take a look at this
jesse when president trump was impeached
the first time it was on the basis of
putting pressure on the ukrainian
president to get negative information on
biden uh and i think we're just running
in a circle here or back to that
incident what do you make of this
i think i speak for everybody on the
show when i say this
rudy giuliani is a national treasure
don't disagree i speak for everyone on
the show
when i say this the guy took on the mob
he took on crime
al qaeda counsel to the president and
now democratic prosecutors want to lock
up a 76 year old icon
for a lobbying technicality one
because he advised the president he
should fire a rotten ambassador
you have to register to lobby for that
hunter biden advised his dad to fire a
prosecutor
did he register where's the raid on
hunter's house
i guess that's not comedy it's actually
now fox news has made it
complicated for us because now that
they have this comedy show gutfeld but
it's not funny
it's really hard to tell when you watch
something is this supposed to be a
comedy show or not but jesse waters i
don't think that's a joke
saying really the rage should be of
hunter biden's house so i don't know if
that's comedy or a serious segment
but just every d if you wrote this into
a screenplay
um hollywood producers would say it's
too over the top just nobody it's it's
implausible
we need to make this less wacky but
unfortunately or maybe fortunately
it's the real story so we'll continue to
follow the situation with
i absolutely love this next story
but it also makes me a little bit
depressed over how
easy it is when your audience is
ignorant to basic facts
it's so easy to convince your audience
of absolute nonsense
as we reported yesterday one of the
things that president joe biden did
at last night's speech before a joint
session of congress
was to propose and outline his 1.8
trillion dollar package that includes
paid family leave child care universal
pre-k
community college and many other things
this is very much a sort of fdr-like
package meant to stimulate the economy
by putting the middle class into a more
stable economic position
it's not really controversial globally
speaking historically speaking
but i guess to the american right wing
it is absolute insanity reminiscent of
bernie sanders's democratic socialism or
something
here are the fox and friends hosts
yesterday morning
reacting incredulously they're beside
themselves
because of joe biden's proposal saying
hey
we elected bernie not joe biden of
course the implication being bernie
the socialist biden is actually bernie
biden is really a socialist
take a look at this biden essentially is
go as jillian said
uh gonna take a victory lap of what he's
been able to accomplish
so far some of the things he promised on
the campaign trail that are going to be
missing from his speech tonight
uh missing lower prescription drug
prices not going to be talking about
that
not going to be talking about expanding
medicare eligibility
and this is really important i know a
lot of you watching
have been curious about the estate tax
he will not be including that campaign
plan to raise the estate tax
from 40 to 45 percent or lower the
exemption from
11 million to 3.5 million because there
are a lot of people
particularly family farm owners who are
very concerned about
that particular position if it went in
they would be sunk
yeah he he'll get around to it trust me
uh america you elected bernie sanders
you just didn't know it
so this is a coded way of saying biden
is a socialist because he wants to
do paid family leave biden is bernie
bernie's a socialist america you now
have a socialist president one reaction
from many people to this clip was
i wish we had elected bernie but a more
kind of on this planet reaction is that
joe biden's proposal
is number one quite moderate by global
standards
number two targeted based on need
and number three really unlikely to pass
is proposed i've said this before i
don't
you know people sometimes get mad they
say david by saying that you're making
it less likely to pass as proposed
no what you hear from a president during
a state of the union or
state of the union like speech is the
framework it's sort of like when the
white house releases a budget the white
house budget is a political document
biden's original proposal is a political
proposal it then gets negotiated so it's
not even like it's going to pass
the way it's actually been proposed uh
for an example i'm in a bunch of
financial planning type circles forums
newsletters and subreddits
for the last two weeks the topic that
keeps coming up among some of the
highest income people in the
these groups is what are you doing based
on joe biden wanting to double the
capital gains tax rate
the most sensible and the most common
answer has been i'm doing nothing yet
why well joe biden is now laying out
what he wants
that will be subject to negotiation it
will almost certainly be watered down
if it passes it might be retroactive to
2021
it might only start in 2022 once we get
there i can decide this is other people
speaking
do i take the gains on my stock and
bonds and pay the capital gains rate
or do i just wait and do nothing and
wait for a future president to change
the rate again and not pay any of that
capital gains rate
the point is people are going nuts as if
biden's ideas are radical
but also as if they're going to pass as
proposed we're at step
0.5 biden told told us what he wants
and then of course there's this really
weird thing weird thing where brian
kilmeade
is slamming biden for the things he is
proposing
whereas steve ducey is slamming biden
for the things that
biden promised but are not part of the
proposal
steve ducey there said you know biden
promised to change the estate tax and
he's not doing it as part of this
shouldn't ducey be happy about that fox
news is part of the estate tax as a
death tax contingent
he should be glad biden's not proposing
it at least for now
but yet he says oh that biden also is
not doing the things he promised to do
of course the real answer is none of it
is about policy
it's never been about policy it's about
posturing to your audience period
biden has proposed something let's now
see what the negotiation
is like and what gets to the floor of
the house and senate and then whether it
passes deal with these things one step
at a time
i have a voicemail here from someone who
is not pleased with my position
on outdoor masks now i think it's really
important for me to state again
my position is that i think i am going
to listen to the cdc on masks
my position has been that all along and
this person
like many in the audience are sort of
upset with me about me saying
i think the cdc is right about pulling
back on outdoor masking in most
situations let's take a listen to this
and go piece by piece
hey david you say you're not for wearing
masks outdoors
again i've been wearing a mask outdoors
this entire time i didn't think it was
necessary
but i've been doing it because i just
follow the cdc guidelines
the cdc guidelines have now changed it's
not that i am for or against
i am listening to the cdc my question
for you
is would you be okay with someone
smoking at the same table as you
outdoors
or smoking right next to the door of
your office building
so i guess two things there smoking at
the same table
i don't really know any smokers so
there's no reason so somebody should be
smoking at my table
if you mean the next table over there's
a bunch of differences here covered
particles
are uh water droplets or aerosolized
liquid if you want to go in that
direction cigarette smoke is smoke
so the physics of it is totally
different coveted particles
aren't carcinogenic they don't have a
cumulative effect
over your lifetime secondhand smoke is
something that it has a
cumulative effect on the body over
lifetime there is some amount
of covered particles that could make you
sick and
if it's below that threshold then that's
it uh accumulating cigarette smoke over
a lifetime is bad so the analogy is the
same one tucker carlson made but it's
it's not a good one
or smoking right next to the open window
of your apartment
i'm guessing you would complain about
that and i'm asking what evidence you
have
that carcinogens in cigarettes aren't
able to move as far
or are able to move further than covet
virus
yeah listen i i these are two completely
different things
smoke is smoke covered particles are are
liquid
so it's just none of it is making sense
to me we also know that it's not like
uh the covet and cigarettes
are also dissimilar in that essentially
no one's getting sick outside
before anybody was vaccinated the
estimate is one out of a thousand cases
were transmitted outdoors
and we have to believe that those few
outdoor cases were people doing
obviously stupid things a big crowd on a
hiking trail or at a concert or whatever
the case may be
there's just no analogy we know it's not
an issue people
have not been getting sick in that way
particles
and i'm also wondering if you're not
for wearing masks outdoors
if someone goes from outdoors to indoors
they put their mask
in their pocket what's preventing the
particles on one side of the mask from
infecting the other side of the mask
well it's in the pocket
and the particles collected on the mask
from getting onto the hands of people
oh god how you how do you expect people
to manage this i don't think most people
can
it's it's what's been done i mean the
entire time you know you go in somewhere
you put your mask on then at some point
the mask goes in your pocket
this is basically surface transmission
surface transmission has been shown to
be
almost zero remember at the beginning
all the stuff about bleach your
vegetables and
uh all of this different stuff it's been
determined it's not necessary
mask in the pocket then on the face the
particles move around
that's not how people are getting sick
so i'm not worried about that there's no
evidence that i need to worry about that
that if it's just in and out of your
pocket you've just moved everything the
mask is collected into your pocket
anyway yeah right but again we now know
that that type of surface-to-surface
stuff
is not how people are getting sick so my
question to these folks is
if you agreed with the cdc all along why
do you suddenly now not
believe what the cdc is saying i've just
been listening to the cdc from the start
um i think that that voicemail is
completely antithetical to any known
science we will have a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about how
americans are seeing biden
compared to barack obama we will talk
about the return of
new york police department's robot dog
and we will talk about a controversial
hand gesture
on jeopardy which may not be what it
seems all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show get access to the
bonus show by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman